they're tall they're blonde they created
IKEA the Nordic country seemed to have
something on the US when it comes to
things like social services and economic
equality we're talking Sweden Norway
Finland Iceland and Denmark so pretty
so what exactly could the u.s. learn
from the happiest people on earth first
how about a shorter workweek in Denmark
people work only 33 hours per week and
get five weeks paid vacation a year and
unemployment benefits can last up to two
years in comparison there is zero
guaranteed paid vacation for US workers
and the average work week is 47 hours
and then there's the awesome free
education Finland is larger consider to
offer the best public education in the
world 93% of Finn's graduate high school
well above the recent all-time high of
81 percent for US students and students
don't have to worry about a life of debt
adult stress if they choose to go to
college in Finland and other Nordic
countries college is free grad school is
free even med school is free in the u.s.
you're looking at a six-figure debt easy
for that kind of schooling free
universal health care also couldn't hurt
in Norway health care is inexpensive and
equally accessible by all citizens
hospital visits and emergency care are
free of charge and out-of-pocket
payments for physician visits or
medications are capped by the government
and finally support families please in
Sweden new parents get more than a year
of parental leave with 90 percent of pay
and this isn't just for new moms dads
who stay at home with their kids for at
least a month earn additional time off
and once the parents are ready to go
back to work Nordic countries subsidized
daycare to make it more affordable for
families whereas in the u.s. there is no
mandatory paid parental leave and
can only take a maximum of 12 weeks of
unpaid time off and daycare in the u.s.
is expensive and unsubsidized in many
places the cost of child care is greater
than the cost of rent so how is this all
possible
well these social programs are funded by
taxes and taxes and nordic countries are
generally much higher of course life in
the land of the north is an all other
perfection Denmark has among the most
household debt of any country and its
work productivity is far below that of
the United States Finland has the
highest murder rate in Western Europe
and Sweden and Norway have become
increasingly Islamophobic and
anti-immigrant so yes there's still a
lot we could learn from these countries
which all place in the top 10 happiest
in the world but with these socialist
inspired policies work in the US